let's have a go at this and yes there is
no how to get some of its leave space
for heading you recall and I can't wait
to do this because actually we just had
this conversation literally just now
that mathematics is not about the
processes right so I don't want you
going through any of these topics
thinking oh okay I learned skill wider
this skill to it's got three and cool I
can do these processes okay there's an
idea there's a concept there's a
principle underneath all of this and
these are just kind of like the
instances of that right we're still
going through so the idea was we
developed this idea of solids of
revolution right and how to work out
their volume and we had amazingly simple
result like that's really quiet elegant
and it's very straightforward to do if
you know the functions expression
equation rather you should go for it to
pass it but if you are willing to lift
the hood a little bit right there's
actually more technical stuff happening
underneath that's disguised by all of
the calculus makes it smooth it over and
makes it nice it starts like know if it
doesn't stop that it's not like a limit
right what's the open so I helped me
remember because this is such an
important result for this case why would
i right does x approaches 0 now i put my
sim really okay I've got some boundaries
already provided and then this part here
aren't even taken a variety of ways I
put a square here because you know I'm
actually in here this isn't radius but
just because I'm already gonna label in
this mythic okay something about that
and then you've got this right so we
recognize what this is saying you are
adding up an infinite number of
infinitesimally thin cylinders and
that's where this pi a square inch
cultural okay so the idea is if you want
me to lift the hood a little bit and say
okay this is actually this is where the
gears working and this is like this belt
that moves that this is where the fuel
goes in if you're willing to work at
that more technical level then you can
muck around with this and you can vary
parts of it okay so this is tables about
just to come up so far we have expanded
what this can do in three particular
ways so here are the headings i want for
a table um
we aren't limited to so this first step
it up here right gives you the tools to
work our volumes in a really nicely way
but only some very specific volumes
right we wanted to go past the
limitations of the hip technique and be
able to say you know you can also if you
lift up wood and change some pieces here
and then you can also do some slightly
differently then we're going to draw
some very simple small diagrams inside
our table just to get a picture of how
far we progressed ok so number one we're
not limited to remember we said Lisa
cylinders yes so we're not limited to
cylindrical slices if what you realize
is you know what I can add up an
infinite number of infinitesimally thin
anything's the units have cylindrical
slices of what was the shape we
introduced it started a the annulus
right so you can have your money you can
have annular slices as well okay so
let's just we did this table and the
small space we've got let's just draw a
diagram so we've got a visual cue what's
going on so you know here is a um here's
a cylindrical slice right and all you
need to do to make that cylindrical
slice into an annular slice years punch
a hole in it writes okay well you're
another similar thing like this right
okay lovely okay so we moved from
cylindrical sizes two annular slices the
only difference up here with that
instead of just of Y square you'd have
an a squared take away ask where you got
a big R little R maybe do okay and then
we said hey this thing is really cool
because it opens up lots of avenue
sports right it enabled us with one of
the very first maybe the first example
no seconds my thing one of the very
early examples we did is rather than
being limited to rotating about a
coordinate axis like the x axis
y axis we can also say what you don't
have to have x equals zero or y equals
zero you kind of x equals anything you
like or y equals anything you like right
so we can rotate about we can also
rotate about any horizontal or vertical
axis and I'll just abbreviate this just
so we can fit in space for a little
diagram right so again for this corner
access right maybe you want to put in a
little diagram like that and if I have
something what's something that shows so
this is a kind of standard sort of
volume to get this kind of um wiki
confit that maybe comes out of a
parabola right that's going around the
corner access but of course if we lift
off and say okay well let's let's go
upwards I think that was the example we
do and let's just take that sample red
line I could rotate it around say y
equals 2y goes 3 or something like that
so i can put instead of my access being
just along that i can lift that off
somewhere i can shift it anywhere I like
and then i can still rotate the same
area this guy under here right if i do
that and it's going upwards instead of
downwards right you're going to get this
kind of shape and i guess it would be
kind of like a ball sort of thing like
it's hollow inside yeah and you've got
this pot here there's an edge that we
can't see so you can see inside this
bowl as it were ok and a city on its
side so that was really cool right um
not just the corner actually speaking
lift off anywhere you like and then
yesterday yesterday what was the next
direction that we're in to remember ok
so actually you know what hey it's cool
you can rotate back every horizontal or
vertical axis spoke who needs to be
horizontal or vertical you don't need to
be losing
to just rotating about those kinds of
axes right the example we looked at
yesterday I think was this the cord the
cord of a circle right and it was off at
this pile for angle which is a bit icky
but I guess you'd say you can also
rotate about a bleak axes ok so we've
already got a diagram for this left hand
situation here it's right there you may
like to just refresh your memory enjoy
yourself now that football thing that we
did yesterday believe it looks something
like this
okay this is fantastic this is pretty
cool you can see you lift the hood and
you can do all kinds of new things
simple idea lots of different
expressions okay but so far all of these
things despite how how different they
are to each other right they all share
one thing in common okay which is that
when you look at all of these different
things all of the other pieces all the
parts that we're dividing up that values
into we've all been cutting them in
exactly the same way we've been we've
talked about this language before in
other words we are cutting perpendicular
to the axis of rotation you notice that
these two here you can see the accident
rotation goes in this direction so
therefore I cut in that direction that
perpendicular yes and that's what gives
us shapes like this over here I have
drawn as one of my cylinders yet but
since the axis of rotation looks like
that then by slices are going to look
like that again at rite aid so maybe I
would roll one like that so all of these
what makes volumes by slicing volumes by
slicing is that you're taking all of
your slices by cutting perpendicular to
the rotation are the axis of rotation
okay